just small tangent but you mentioned uh
having a conversation with warren
buffett you spoke really highly of him
as an investor as a human being
what about him do you admire what uh
what
what from him what insights have you
drawn from him as a as a great investor
yourself
well the afternoon that i got to spend
with him which you know something i'll
treasure forever look sometimes when you
meet people even that are immensely
successful
you
you may decide that after
20 minutes or a half hour oh
you were in the right place at the right
time and
you know that's that's fine uh there are
other people
that are clearly different special and i
don't care if you made them start from
zero
you know would would end up in a good
place
and so it was it was a absolute
privilege to spend the time with him
um
you know and a couple of things that
stood out in the conversation
um
he is incredibly intellectually curious
and well-read
and i like how simplistic he likes to
keep his thought matrix
and then also
instead of trying to outsmart the market
it seems like a simple axiom but just
look
good companies that are led by talented
managers
that are good businesses over time
are gonna get there so i'm not gonna day
trade i'm not i'm just gonna i'm looking
for
uh for value and then just on
life stuff he just
you know and also his
ability to take in
and then use
information
uh it was incredibly impressive so uh i
only spent the you know i'd met him
before but i only spent one afternoon
with him but it's
you know pretty incredible and one of
the things that stuck out to me
is we were in the middle of talking
about
tulco or investing or how we thought
about it and i said uh you know i'm
trying to be smart about
and he stopped me and he said charlie
munger his partner of many years charlie
and i don't try to think of the smart
thing to do
we try to think what's the dumb thing we
could do here
and i kind of laughed and he said no i'm
i'm dead serious
we think about it from the standpoint of
what could we do in this situation that
later we'd be like that was a really
dumb thing to do and i actually thought
that was
me it got in my head and i i still think
a lot about that as i'm as i'm
dissecting problems
so there is uh
like
that's a kind of long-term thinking if
you just avoid the dumb things
or if you uh if you simplify ever
just focus on those simple steps
all it takes is just do that for a long
period of time and you'll be successful
well it certainly worked for him that's
all i can say what about what about you
uh you've been
uh a great investor yourself how do you
know
when you judge people
so i whenever i go to san francisco i
was thinking of moving to san francisco
that's why that's why i decided to after
really giving us some thought talking to
people decided to move to austin
you know um
everybody's dreaming big and they have
big plans and it's actually
i don't envy the job of an investor
of any kind
because everybody has big dreams and
it's hard to know who exactly
what idea is going to materialize
what what team is going to materialize
into something great how do you make
those decisions about people about ideas
well
if i had any kind of a
lattice work on this
it start absolutely starts with the
people and i think the reason for that
is
your business plan
is going to change
right there's very few businesses i know
of that say we're going to make a widget
in this location
and 30 years later
we're successful and we just make a
widget and that's what it is
things happen right and today they
happen with such velocity
that
you have to be able to make
hard decisions based on imperfect
information
and are you
how are you going to calculate those
answers
how self-interested are you going to be
what kind of ethics will you apply
what's your short-term versus long-term
thinking are you able to give an honest
assessment of a situation
um
because the thing that you can count on
is problems are going to happen
things you didn't anticipate are going
to happen
how pliable are you
right how how much elasticity is there
in in your ability
uh to to be successful and i think
it's important when you invest in
something that you both see
you you understand the road map ahead
and agree to it
right doesn't mean there won't be twists
and turns but you're not like well wait
a minute what did we do here i this
isn't what was in the
the thing i signed up for
um
and then i i think
honesty and communication is a huge
thing to me with
you know i always tell people if
bi-directionally
if there's something going on start the
conversation with
you know lex we have a problem
okay now
i'm sitting up you have my full
attention we're going to talk about
whatever it is
bad news should travel faster than good
news
and because
it's going to happen
being in business with someone that is
going to shoot you straight
and sometimes say i don't know
yeah i don't know what the answer is i
got to go figure it out
that i can process a lot better
than look i i don't want you mad at me
or disappointed or i i can't handle not
having success so we're just gonna
kick the can and
i i think especially in today's business
environment that's very very
dangerous so that's a bad sign not just
because it's uh good to do to
communicate and be honest but if if
they're not willing to do that then it
goes back to the intellectual honesty
they're probably not also able to be
brutally honest with themselves when
they look in the mirror about the
direction of the company but look i i
wasn't there so i don't know but i think
if you unpack
many situations that turned out
negatively
most of the people whether you're faking
lab results right you have a biotech
company we have everybody's staring at
theranos these days
do i think in a lot of cases
you're either the villain like you
started out saying i'm i'm gonna screw
my shareholders over and i'm going to be
a liar
that
that that isn't my experience
most things are little incremental moves
that you say
we're going to get this right next week
but today we got to make the
presentation so we're going to just
tweak things a little bit that's a
slippery slope
right and so
that's why i think from a standpoint of
people
you want to go into the foxhole with
folks that
you know understand
things are going to happen and i'm going
to let you know about them and we're
going to try to solve them
uh together
and and then just in terms of the idea
it's
i always ask like okay if this company
executed the way that's the other thing
always cracks me up about financials
whenever somebody pitches you
inevitably they'll say our projections
are really really conservative
i'm i'm still waiting for somebody to
come in and say look my projections are
wildly optimistic we'll never hit these
numbers but
anyway um
it's uh
you know if this company did what it
says and executes and does it matter
yeah right does it move the needle
enough and and what are the
what are the things that uniquely
position this company to be successful
and you just have to be able to answer i
think a number of those questions uh
pretty crisply
but at the end of the day it's still a
big risk so you're just trying to
try to minimize the risk
you